[Music]
22 years later it ain't no lie nsyncs
bye bye bye
it's still a bop and the ultimate
wedding song
[Music]
the seemingly impromptu performance went
down over the weekend at singer ryan
cabrera's wedding to wwe star alexa
bliss among the star-studded crowd three
members from nsync joey fatone chris
kirkpatrick and lance bass
this lance bass
oh my god he's here
he made it is that lance pass
where are you going joe it's chris
whatever where are you going joe
where you going joe after the couple
exchanged vows the guests hit the dance
floor and were treated to the ultimate
early 2000s performance from the guys
themselves
[Music]
but you'll notice only three of nsync's
five singers are there justin timberlake
and jc chaze were notably absent but
always there in our hearts
even the bride got in on the action
nailing those sweet dance moves
[Music]
alexa shared her gratitude on instagram
writing thank you for letting me be part
of such an epic moment it's fun and it's
fun seeing the singer still so close
after all this time let's rewind back to
the late 90s when the band rose to fame
with hits like
[Music]
and after two decades as bandmates
they're still going strong even if it
means a member of two popping up here
and there with singers from their rival
boy band
[Music]
yeah that's lance and joey rehearsing
with two of the backstreet boys nick
carter and aj mclean for a special
mash-up concert benefiting the trevor
project
we've all worked together in some way
shape or form individually i mean they
could work together obviously and aj
lance's work is working with nick now
lance has done things with aj so it's
kind of cool to see the four of us
together and they're always my favorite
backstreet boys
[Applause]
[Music]
but the only thing cooler than seeing
the guys together on stage is seeing
them thrive as dads it's very emotional
for sure after welcoming twins in
october lance shared the precious pick
when uncle joey and uncle chris met his
little ones sometimes it doesn't seem
real you know i'm like wait a minute i'm
a dad wait what is this uh but it's just
the overwhelming feeling is just so much
love you know everyone always told us
you don't know love until you have your
kids and it's true it's a whole
different type of love
[Music]
you